lucas giolito goes to the hill for his
eighth start he's two and three is era
of four and a half
however strike out to walk ratio has
been very good left-handers because of
that change we've done nothing with him
the right-handers have hurt him a bit
and the key today is the man you look at
at the top with mary field will be pitch
number eight
and it is outside whit certainly earned
that walk here is carlos santana healthy
lead for mere field he does not run and
santana hits it
and garcia makes a call in the catch so
a 3-1 fly out is a big first out for
lucas through ben and tendy who's been
swinging one of the hottest bats in the
kansas city lineup as he stands in there
swinging a miss on a changeup
for gia lito's first strikeout that was
a dandy he had ben and tendy way out in
front so two outs merrifield still stuck
at first base and es salvador perez
who's batted 317 against right-handed
pitching this season ground ball to
third moncado will glove his throw to
abreu is true
perez is out giallito works around the
lead-off walk and like lucas giolito
brad keller faces his opponent for the
second time in a week keller has a
little bit more riding on it though he's
he's got to carry the entire team on his
back tim anderson leads off
that is ball four and a lead off walk
for tim anderson just as the royals
began the top of the first with a lead
off walk swing and a miss he struck him
out at a 94 mile an hour heater up so
keller follows the walk with his first
strikeout here comes mankato as moncada
tags this into left field tim's gonna
sprint for third and he was on the move
and he will easily get there so the run
game gets an extra base for the sox as
monkata and anderson go first and third
the batter is jose abreu who led the
american league in rbis last year with
60.
jose line drive to right tim's coming
home and it's one-nothing socks in a
seven-inning ball game
one-nothing here's your mean mercedes
and that is a high slider for ball four
so keller has thrown a boatload of
pitches in the first he has not been
able to hit with his slider first and
second and yes monty grand all will
check in here's the 2-2 pitch and it's a
breaking ball a cold strike three on the
inside corner a delayed call from home
plate umpire dan bellino oh my gosh that
was not at all a strike the first hit
for kansas city in the bowl game one on
for dozier this has popped up
abraham runs in to the runner dozier
and the catch is made abreu got
clobbered and dozier's down and jose is
down oh my goodness full speed into one
another dozier was going around the
catcher grand all and by the time he
looked up abreu was right there and i
don't think either guy
saw anything it just takes your breath
away oh my goodness
i think for both dozier and abraham that
was so violent that they're hurting
everywhere right now this is just
horrible and it's michael a taylor in
the box and the ball hit well to right
field and deep
eaton is at the wall and it's gone and
michael a taylor
goes to the opposite field on the first
pitch
after the long delay
and the royals take a 2-1 lead in the
second inning brad keller pitches with
the lead he had a 36 pitch first inning
slider in there strike three calls i
didn't even have to wait for the delayed
call from dan bellino and keller's third
strikeout check swing did he go they say
he did and that's a rare strikeout for
nick madrigal and two in the inning and
a one two three frame good bounce back
inning for brad keller and the royals
have him at the corners with one away
and
sal perez coming up first pitch swinging
has been a theme against giolito he'll
swing and shoot it down the right field
line going back is eaton eating in front
of the fence looks up it's gone a three
run opposite field home run
salvador perez extends the royals lead
it's 5-1 kc
two on nobody out in the batter grand
all two and two and the pitch
and a swing and a miss and he struck him
out that was the slider down and in
six strikeouts for brad keller so now
one out with runners at the corners and
the batter will be
young hot-hitting andrew vaughn in the
air right field so lair has a play
the sox will get a run collins from
third on his way home and they do pay
off the lead off double at least it is
five to two in the fourth inning that's
through and madrigal will bat in this
fourth inning here's the one two and a
swing and a miss and a slider in the
dirt and cam gallagher has the out
number three so they've struck out twice
incredible so seventh strikeout for brad
keller that's a lead-off hit and adam
eaton will be the hitter grounded to the
right side and the royals get the lead
runner and a double play
that's how you pick up your pitcher
who's been falling behind on some of
these hitters look at that look at
everything coaching staff's energized oh
get collins to the plate and a fastball
pulled to win in short right field he'll
throw two first for the out
4-3 put out ends the inning and brad
keller has pitched five innings he's
allowed two runs
he's got his team set up perhaps to end
the losing streak concert alberto
against lucas giolito back out there for
the sixth oh two change up alberto has
not seen the change up well from g alito
and two at bats at all there's number
six for g alito today because there's a
change up for strike three and two gone
in this sixth he's got seven strikeouts
way up in the air off the bat of cam
gallagher
and
monkata straddling the line battling the
sun royals go in order in the sixth it's
getting late brad keller leaves the
contest with a five to two lead and now
hands that baseball to his quality
bullpen and that starts with scott
barlow and mercedes strikes out so he
started him off with a slider he put him
away with a slider and that's one away
in the sixth swung on and missed he
struck him out so back-to-back case for
barlow and both on his best pitch that
breaking ball right down the heart of
the plate strike three called great job
by scotty strikes out the side now
runner at second one out pitch to
santana pulls it to the right side and
through that's a base hit lopez turns
third he'll race home with the royals
sixth run and casey takes a four-run
lead on chicago josh stamont comes on in
a non-save situation but if you're a
royal or a royals fan this is a save no
matter how you look at it because the
royals are three outs away from putting
an end to an 11-game losing streak
anderson strikes out as ken hawk
harrelson the great chicago white sox
announcer would say
for the royals this 11-game losing
streak is over